this is a production of Cornell
University well it's wonderful to be
here it's wonderful to see old friends
and and colleagues that I'm working with
now collaborating and also to to be in a
place with snow coming down you know I
came from nine inches and now I brought
it with me so you might get nine inches
it's really a pleasure to be here and I
obviously didn't do the math very well
when I accepted that international
typology Society presidency because I'll
be President in 2023 I'm a president now
but it'll be 2023 then when the meeting
is and obviously I'm not that young
anymore so I don't do math very well but
today I'd liked it I'm gonna talk to you
about something that I don't
I haven't often talked about so a lot of
people aren't aware that we're working
in this area but it stems from the fact
that we're we're very interested and I
have been for my whole career interested
in so I started my career at Kansas
State and back then for those of you who
are young it's a little bit different
because when I went into Kansas they
said that I could work on any system I
wanted to as a plant pathologist
understanding that as a plant microbe
interaction person we were called
disease physiologist at the time that we
would maybe choose model systems and so
I had worked in tobacco and fostonia so
on a serum for my PhD and then
verticillium in hops for my postdoc and
I thought well I really want to work in
what a choice to have to get to choose
what you want to work with I wanted to
work on an important crop and I wanted
to work on important diseases of an
important crop so I cast around and
asked questions called my major
professor Louisa Cara and said what
would you do if you had it to do over
again
he said I'd work on sigatoka in banana
or I'd work in Xanthomonas arise Ian
Rice
about the time I started in Xanthomonas
Ric and rice they had discovered race
specificity so the idea that there might
be single dominant resistance genes
I knew that rice was a diploid so it
would be a tractable system relative to
wheat which is the state I was in Kansas
had a lot of wheat and that the bacteria
was Xanthomonas arise arise e that
causes bacterial blight would probably
be genetically tractable back then it
wasn't but it probably would be at some
point in evolution of the back of my
career so I started working in this
really important disease which is is
still B major disease in rice although
Xanthomonas are basically as you'll see
is emerging as an important disease of
rice so the idea the my interest was
could I apply my microbiology and my
plant physiology back then we were
called skills from my PhD to solving
this intractable problem well we haven't
done that yet but you know there are
still jobs out there for people because
the issue really is that this disease is
fairly well controlled by single gene
resistance and the single dominant genes
are sort of the the mainstay for
resistance but the problem is as you
well know in plant pathology I don't
need to tell people this that you plant
out sources of resistance they're
functional for many years then you vtec
virulence in the pathogen population the
pathogen changes to overcome that
resistance so we have a continuous job
we have to keep identifying new
resistance in rice it can take up to 10
to 15 years to find and integrase a new
disease resistance gene so if we're
breaking down as can occur within five
or less years it's not really a
tractable system we need to come up with
other ways so I've spent a large part of
my career
trying to figure out what I call the
Holy Grail and many of other people call
it this too which is what how can we
identify disease resistance that is not
only long-lasting but ideally effective
against multiple pathogens either
multiple races of the same pathogen or
multiple pathogens like different
bacterial diseases or bacteria and fungi
or different fungal diseases and I think
the Holy Grail is a good example because
by definition it not only provides
happiness and eternal youth which of
course we'd all love but it is it also
provides food in infinite abundance so
today the story I'm going to tell you is
a story about identifying resistance in
different kinds of novel populations and
I'm going to tell you the story that
onna Bosa her PhD work where she was
looking for resistance in rice that is
effective against both two bacterial
pathogens which we'll talk about in a
minute
so broad-spectrum resistance and
specifically targeting Africa and the
reason is because both of these diseases
are emerging is really important in
Africa and not only that but there's no
single gene resistance for bacterial
leaf streak so it's a problem and and
they're being because they're moving
rice in from China into Africa and the
those those types of rice are
susceptible to the African strains of
these pathogens and we're so they're
having a big problem with the disease in
Africa and then I'm going to move into a
second story because it uses the same
magic population I'll show you the power
of this magic population by a postdoc in
the lab Alejandra Huerta and Emily
DeLorean who was a master's student in
the lab so the two diseases that will
will be featured today are caused by
Xanthomonas array Ziggler which is
bacterial leaf streak of right
this is really an interesting disease
because and the difference between these
diseases is really interesting this is
an intercellular pathogen it enters the
plant through the stow mates and it
moves in the plant in the intercellular
spaces
whereas Xanthomonas arise arise ii very
closely related genetically is a
vascular pathogen it enters the plants
either through wounds or the height of
food water forests which are located on
the edges of the leaf and it causes a
blight like symptom so two very similar
pathogens but two very different
lifestyles so finding resistance that's
effective against both could be a bit of
a challenge one might think as I
mentioned earlier bacterial leaf streak
is emerging as a major problem in parts
of Asia and in Africa it's actually
thought that it used to be observed only
on one side of the ANSI River in China
now it's observed on both sides of the
ANSI River and they're thinking a lot of
it is because of climate variation and
impacts of weather on the on the on the
system in this case we don't have single
dominant resistance gene the only single
dominant resistance genes that we have
to this pathogen or one that we
identified from Mays years ago which is
we've introduced in the inter ice
controls the disease but otherwise they
usually use quantitative traits type
Louis I or quantitative trait governed
resistance to control this disease so
there are limited resistant sources for
it not only in Asia but also in Africa
and it's a bacterial blight as I
mentioned as a vascular pathogens
controlled by single genes but there are
a few sources of resistance that have
been identified that are effective
against the African eye slits of this
pathogen so let me introduce you to the
population that we used to identify
sources of resistance so my colleagues
at the International Rice Research
Institute
few years back developed what are called
rice magic populations and these
populations are multi parent advanced
generation populations and and folks may
have worked with them in there there are
now magic populations not only in rice
but also in in wheat and other also
Arabidopsis the this population has
eight parents so you can imagine you can
imagine the genetics that you're
scrambling when you're intercrossing
eight parents and we'll talk about how
it's done but I want you to notice this
is the population there are two thousand
lines planted out at Erie where they're
propagating it I want you to notice how
even the pop how beautifully even it is
it's because in this particular case
eight of the parents that were selected
our elite varieties but they have
different traits of interest so what
that means and importantly what that
means is that anything that we identify
in this population is very close it's
like a pre breeding material it's very
close to what the breeders can use to
integrate into other elite varieties you
don't have a lot of genetic drag from
other things so the other reason it's
nice is because not only did they select
those eight parents for useful traits
like disease resistance drought
tolerance salt tolerance phosphorus
utilization but the population is huge
there are 21,000 magic lines so when you
map in that population you're you're
almost getting down to the genes of
interest and the offspring as I
mentioned can be integrated directly
into breeding programs so I'm not going
to spend a lot of time on this because
I'm not the person that developed it and
it's a pretty complicated process and
long term process but you take the eight
parents and you do a series of crosses
and in fact you've crossed at least
three times to develop this particular
population and
and after you've done you've finished
crossing you start selfing and then
yourself in our case we use the s8 so
you get rid of any other extraneous
information but you have really a single
that is a true line once you get it so
essentially you have 21,000 isogenic
lines once you get down to this and they
breed true because rice is a selfing
population so this is really powerful
but we but really they hadn't explored
the utility of it for disease resistance
they had a little bit of work on that
but not much
so when Anna came into my lab we wanted
to ask the question of could we use this
magic lines the series of magic lines to
identify disease sources of disease
resistance that are novel and that are
effective against both Xanthomonas arise
arise either bacterial blight pathogen
and Xanthomonas tricyclic the bacterial
leaf straight pathogen and we focused on
the African strains because we had this
issue of the disease being prevalent in
Africa but no sources of resistance so
the first step was to genotype the
materials and that was done by
genotyping by sequencing so we have a
14,000 snips that we were using so not
the entire suite of snips but 14,000 and
we screened a subset of the s8
population so really fixed lines and we
did about 330 lines and the importance
of that is that's not a huge population
to screen but you'll see it's very
effective so we could identify sources
of resistance in a very small population
we phenotyped with the two diseases the
vascular disease we use a scissor clip
to introduce it into the vessels the the
intercellular pathogens we infiltrate
into the space and so the experiment was
done with 20 different very diverse
anthem on a tricycle and a rise II
strains 10 each and we not only did this
in the greenhouse replicated in the
greenhouse over time but we also with
our colleagues in Africa screen in the
field because obviously if you're
looking for resistance it has to be
effective in the field then all of that
data is taken and integrated and
analyzed and because we're using a huge
population with multiple parents you can
started you can do G wasps analysis or
genome-wide Association analysis as well
as interval mapping so what did we find
and I'm not going to give you the whole
experimental process that Ani used to
get to the steps because I want to move
into the second set of work but this is
an example of one set of strains you can
see that the indica was segregating or
resistance and you can see typically
that you have transgressive segregation
where you have lines that are more
susceptible than the eight parents and
in often cases we have lines that are
more susceptible or more resistant than
the most resistant parent and this is
just two of the different pathogens that
were used in the inoculation one or Z
and one a right siccola so that's good
we know that the population oh I forgot
to tell you an important point the other
good thing about the magic because
you're scrambling the genomes you you
can do two things you can create new
novel resistances because you get
recombination and you can uncover
resistances that you might not have seen
in a particular parent because of its
genetic background so with a population
like this you have many obvious
opportunities for creating new sources
of resistance
so onna in the jiwa studies was able to
identify sources of resistance to not
only Xanthomonas arise arise e bacterial
blight as you can see from this but also
when she did identify those sources of
resistance we what was wonderful was
this doesn't always happen and it's it's
in general true but not always true
we couldn't confirm what we identified
in g wasps by the interval mapping that
doesn't always happen but that's a good
indicator that what we're seeing is
really real and in fact the most
important piece of information is that
we saw we were able to recapitulate what
we saw in the greenhouse in the field in
mali so in the end what she ended up
with was a map and there and that map
includes resistances so she identified
14 different QTL that were effective to
multiple Xanthomonas arise east rains
and both Xanthomonas arise E and arise
Achilles she got eleven broad spectrum
resistances that those regions conferred
resistance to both pathogens with very
different lifestyles and then she was
able to identify three paths of our
specific QTL so this is great but what's
most interesting is this one here on
chromosome 4 because the stars indicate
and the bars indicate different eye
slits and you can see that the one on
chromosome four hit a lot of eye slits
so that is a source of resistance that
we had never observed in any other
population and what's interesting about
it is that when we look at that region
we can see because we can map this with
both gos and integral mapping we can
actually get down to what snips are
important for resistance and which snips
are important for susceptibility
relative to the different eye slits so
that helps
narrow into the region with the jeans
and it was effective against many of the
eye slits that we had screened it with
from the field in the field and in the
greenhouse so a major contribution in
that particular aspect so to summarize
this part using the magic population
which we didn't know if we were going to
be able to see sources of resistance to
either the pathogens really I mean there
were there were a few single dominant
resistance genes in the population we
saw them but we we were able to pull out
11 different genes that were effective
against both pathogens which is huge and
that one on chromosome four is one that
were focused on still and again it was
confirmed in both the greenhouse in the
field again this is important because
now that we have this line these lines
with for example this chromosome for QTL
or this region of resistance we can
begin to integrate this into varieties
that are useful in both Africa and in
Asia for that matter so with that as a
backdrop we now knew that this
population was manageable and we could
we didn't have to screen all 2100 lines
in order to identify something we we
thought okay let's start to see if we
can begin to ask questions with that the
population that we've been interested in
for some time and so Alejandra led this
project with the help of Anna I want to
point out mapping with eight parents
that are scrambled up is not trivial
and the program's the analytical
programs to do the G wasps and interval
mapping we're just being developed as
Anna was doing this project so she was
on the phone with this this molecular
mapper the the bioinformatics person who
originally was in the Philippines then
was in Australia and now is it a company
in California Anana was continuing
they were wonderful about working with
her so she became a really valuable
resource for the rest of the work in the
lab and learned a lot more than she
expected to about these populations so
the next question was can we use this
population to identify rice varieties
that target specific effectors in
pathogens and why would we want to do
that why is that of interest so many of
you especially in this department where
Adam Bogdanov is know that tally factors
are the dominant effector families in
Santha moments and in fact Xanthomonas
arrays and Xanthomonas anthem ELISA
Rosie Rosie and Xanthomonas arrays ERISA
Cola have multiple copies of tally
factors so these are transcription
activator like effectors there the major
virulence factors for these pathogens
they have other effectors but these are
the major ones the effectors are
produced in the bacteria pumped into the
plant cell using a type 3 secretion
system once in the plant cell they're
mobilized into the nucleus they bind to
the promoters of genes in the plant and
they activate the transcription of those
genes we'll come back to that in a
little bit
the Xanthomonas arise e strains that we
work with have multiple copies of the
tally factors they can have up to 20 or
more copies of these effector genes and
again they bind to these sequences in
the plant and activate their expression
now there are several important factors
here not all of the tally factors
function and not all of them function
equally in the plant so a number of
years ago but Gionta by when he was in
the lab showed that if you knock out one
gene a ver XA 7 you reduce virulence of
the pathogen significantly and
interestingly if he knocked if you knock
that gene out it's a major effect tally
effector so in order to see the effect
of other tally factors we had
to work with that mutant and knock out
other genes so this is a double mutant
and you see that there's no additional
effect when he knocked out a ver x8 n we
continued to work with that particular
set of isolates and we also did field
studies nollie veracruz when she was in
the lab and we showed that at the field
level a number of years back back in
2000 that if you lose a VXR a
sevenfunction in the field not only do
you lose the effector function the a
virulence function the but you also lose
the Offit's of the pathogen or the
aggressiveness and reduce fitness in the
field so it doesn't persist in the
population so it seems to be a very very
very important Fitness factor so with
that work we at that time proposed a
hypothesis that you could predict the
durability of a resistance gene based on
its contribution to pathogen fitness so
Ava X a7 is a very important effector
and therefore if a resistance gene
targets that that fit that resistance
gene is probably going to be more
effective and durable in the field than
one that targets a 4x a 10 and in fact
nolle showed that in fields experiments
and in greenhouse experiments that that
if you lose a TRX a sevenfunction in the
field if there's mutation in the field
to that you lose the pathogen doesn't
persist and that is a very effective
resistance gene so we thought well there
are other effectors in Xanthomonas arise
e and we had looked at a number of these
other effectors doing similar studies
like this and one of them stood out
because it was called tau 7b it's also a
tally factor it's it's found in the
genomes of many different the
Xanthomonas arise e but this one has
only an increment
or a minor contribution tubulin so if
you knock it out as well as a 4x a seven
you get an incremental increase decrease
in the virulence so our question was
also this one is found in almost all the
sequence anthem Anasazi genomes so it's
present everywhere it has a minor
contribution to resistance so if we
identify sources of resistance to tau 7b
could that be added to our gene pool for
resistance to help stabilize and make
the resistance more durable since so
many bacteria have it even if it's only
contributing a little bit to virulence
is it contributing more to other things
like fitness in the field so Alejandra
and her colleagues set up an experiment
similar to what Allah had done we took
the genotype lines we phenotype them in
this case we sub cloned and confirmed
first that we had tell 7b they put it
into a strain where we were over
expressing it purposefully because it's
a minor effect and we're screening a
population you need to have a pretty
hefty gene product in order to do that
and then went through the mapping
process so importantly the magic lines
segregate for resistance initially you
can see that they segregate we have a
transgressive segregation again we're
seeing higher levels of susceptibility
so I'm going to talk to you in a minute
about the function of tau effectors and
so that's not surprising but you have
the population has lines that are more
susceptible than the parent that also
implies importantly that you can map for
susceptibility if you want to understand
virulence in a population the other
interesting point to this is that we
were able to identify resistance to both
p XO 2 p XO 99 with
the empty vector so this is the control
strain so we have lines that are more
resistant than the parent as well as
lines that are more resistant to the PX
o99 the strain with the Tau 78 vector so
importantly for us to move forward the
magic population contains lines with
resistance and susceptibility to tell 7b
now it's not surprising that tell 7b
showed like showed that virulence
function that it's headlines that would
it caused more disease because we knew
it was a variance factor before we
started and we confirmed that in this
study so this the bottom line on this
one in the G wasps analysis we saw
resistance to arise e PX o99 with the
empty vector so the population shows
resistance to the strain that we were
using to screen with not surprising in
fact we know that this is the AVR I'm
sorry the xa5
locus which Susan the couch worked with
a number of years ago and that those you
can see those same low sigh were
identified when we put the towel 7b into
the strain and also we found that there
was resistance that was unique to the
strain carrying towel 7b so we
identified two low sy that conferred
resistance to tell 7b specifically if it
was in the strain that had 99 the strain
px on 99 and also importantly for us
this was confess all these QTL or these
regions were confirmed by interval
mapping so what's so interesting about
tally effectors well there are there are
different ways and how is tell 7b
potentially acting in this line and can
we predict something about how this
might be how this resistance might be
functioning by understand
something about tell 7b this is so tell
7b our tally factors in general are
known to interact with plants in
generally in three different ways
in one case they bind to the promoter of
what we is called a death gene a typical
resistance gene type function and they
activate expression of that gene and you
get cell death something like a
hypersensitive response and the x8n AVR
x8n interaction is an example of that
another example of how Tali effectors
interact with plant genes is that they
bind to the promoter of the
susceptibility genes and when they bind
they activate expression of that
susceptibility gene and you get
increased disease the hypothesis is for
example that these sweet genes might be
did the delivering helping to deliver
sugar out to feed the bacteria the other
hypothesis or other mechanism that's
been demonstrated is where you have
instead of activation of a death gene
you have mutations or changes in the
promoter or the nearby the promoter that
don't allow the Tile effector to bind
and you don't get activation of
susceptibility and therefore you have
resistance by loss of susceptibility so
it's not a hypersensitive type of
resistance it's just the lack of disease
so we asked the question how is the
resistance to tell 7g functioning in
these plants can we develop a hypothesis
and predict what's happening by looking
at this interaction so if you look at a
number of the magic lines as well as a
control line again this is the empty
vector this is the overexpressed house
7b you can see that we have an enhanced
susceptibility or enhanced virulence
enhance disease longer lesions in these
lines that we're not showing resistance
and this is most of the population right
so this would suggest
the Tao 7b is activating a
susceptibility gene is one hypothesis
that we can test if we look at the lines
that and it's it and it's consistent
with the whole population if we look at
the lines where we saw resistance
especially related to this QTL that we
identified on chromosome 8 that
conferred resistance to tell 7b we see
that there's no enhanced appearance how
7b is not increasing the virulence of 99
as it did as it did on the other lines
and in this case we would predict or we
would hypothesize that we have either a
change in the promoter region or a
nearby the promoter region that is where
the tabie cannot enhance virulence
because it's not activating the
susceptibility gene so the lines that
have the QT l8 in them are consistent
with a loss of susceptibility for the
for the mechanism for resistance well
the beauty of the towel effector world
is that you can predict where what the
target is in the plant because the towel
effector code has been broken by a
demand and other work people and we know
how to predict what tell 7b should bind
to based on the code and in fact using
several bioinformatics tools that have
been developed to ask what it binds to
Alejandra
pulled out a set of putative targets
that it might be binding to and
activating in the plant
and as you can see she hit on a lot of
the genes that you would predict might
be true but she also hit on some other
ones that are known to be involved in
defense responses but not necessarily
had shown to be involved in these
interactions and these are genes that
lie within the QTL that she identified
and one of the interesting ones for
example is that's not a sweet gene is
this search gene because she sees a snip
in the pin in the EBE the potential
effect your binding domain that's
actually close to the start but not in
the promoter but very close to it in
that particular gene so I hope I've
convinced you that magic is a powerful
tool for discovery of resistance and
characterization of novel tali vectors
we screened these 330 lines and
interestingly we were working with the
s8 generation which means that they had
taken the lines and self them eight
times eight generations we actually
performed the analysis in an earlier
generation the s4 generation and
essentially they landed on the same low
sigh so what that means is we maybe
don't have to go out eight generations
to fix the lines and discover the things
that we mean we identified novel
broad-spectrum resistance sources that
target both XO c and XO o in those
populations and we also identified QTL
that target a specific effector two
regions that target a specific effector
and we proposed that the resistance
mechanism we have a hypothesis that we
can now test is that the resistance
mechanism for one of those is through a
loss of susceptibility so the other
important point is that all of these
sources you know as a plant breeder you
don't know
barely care what what the mechanism is
they're more interested in getting a
useful and dynamic source of resistance
that a little stand stand up in the
field and so now we can introduce these
effectively into not into elite
varieties and then we can begin to ask
the question do they in fact increase
the durability in the field populations
and are they broad-spectrum at a field
scale in the elite variety backgrounds
so I maybe talked a little faster than I
intended or a little sore but I want to
thank our many collaborators especially
our colleagues at in Mali in Africa who
did the field screening led by Valery
vedere from France Alejandra and Anna
here and I and my lab group along with
Herman who comes to my lab in the summer
to get out of Texas and many of you
recognize him and also to our many
funding sources Anna was supported by a
becha Borlaug scholarship and Alejandra
by an NSF scholarship so with that I'm
happy to take any questions yeah
transcriptomic changes yes yes and
that's that's what she's doing right now
absolutely yeah because that's the next
step is to test which of those genes is
involved by the way I neglected to say
I'm not surprised that we have multiple
genes I mean we're talking about
quantitative traits and we've got two
different ones these tally factors could
target multiple genes in fact they
probably do and so I and and so I'm not
at all surprised about that in fact I
would bet that
we will see more of that as we move
through looking at each gene and then
she's doing that right now she she's got
the lines growing and getting everything
out to test fit hypothesis so it'll be
really exciting yeah there was sort of
natural I'm not sure no in fact it was
inoculated they had the pots and they
inoculated the pots from the outside
yeah same group of strains with a few
exceptions we couldn't put any
Philippine strains in Mali we could only
put the Malian strains so we only had
two agents in our study anyway so yeah
focus was effected against both strains
but against all individuals of those
things the the one locus on chromosome
four was effective at a statistic level
against all I'm not all almost all I
think it was like 18 or so out of it out
of the 20 18 or something like that
probably the statistics it probably
showed some level of resistance remember
this is quantitative and we're measuring
lesions the other Louis I were against a
few strings of each so that's why we're
we're more interested in that one on
chromosome four I don't know what to say
about the ones that are effective
against a few strains of arising a few
strains of erisa Cola because the towel
effect are compliments in ERISA and
ERISA Clah are different so I wouldn't
expect that to be a reason I would
expect it to be something else yeah I
was your your laboratory phenotyping you
are seeing resistance phenotype with
lesion lengths the third last half plus
or whatever in the field is that just as
that resistance magnified much more in a
field setting or is it is it a partial
kind of resistance it's a partial
resistance
I don't know how it compares I can't I
had forgotten them yeah yeah yeah oh is
it would it be effective in the field if
it was just a partial yeah yeah yeah you
know I don't remember the numbers now
but I know that it was it it was clearly
resistant more resistant but I don't
know I don't know how it compared
proportionately that's a good question
I'll have to go back and look at that
data yeah you can do both with magic
yeah we use the same population it's
just two different mapping strategies
with two different premises so G vas is
a population you're looking at a sort of
looking for a population where as
interval mapping is and again this is
where I'm the weakest I'm not the plant
geneticist but an interval mapping
you're looking for Association of a
trait with a particular region of the
genome rather than comparing across to
the population does that make sense yeah
yeah but that's one of the nice things
about this because we can do both types
of mapping because it's really a
population as you have 8 genotypes
scrambled so you can do both types but
you can't use the standard mapping tools
that are developed for a by parental
population that's why we had to work
with the folks that we're developing the
tools for the eight parent populations I
should say this is an indica population
so those of you who know rice there's
also a japonica magic population and
there's what's called a global
population which is they took the eight
from the japonica and the eight from the
indica and cross them so sixteen parents
now there are a lot of genetic problems
when you
but japonica an indica together and so
there are some problems with that
population but it's still useful for
these kinds of things identifying these
kinds of traits because it doesn't
matter if you're missing parts of the
chromosome didn't recombine you don't
really care if you identify something
useful create efficiency well
interesting you should ask that there
are a couple well I'm sorry
so yes if there are attempts to create
artificial gene sequences that would
increase the resistance so I you notice
that you may or may not have noticed I
took promoter amount of the title
because I had a another part that I was
going to present that would have
increased the link that are talked
considerably we know a lot about the
activation of defense responses
downstream of these events and it's
common whether it be single ETA single
gene resistance governed versus QTL
govern there's a lot of commonality of
what's induced those are the defense
response genes downstream and a graduate
student in my lab Brad identified
conserved structural regions in the
promoters of the genes that have
elements that are ins that are conserved
in defense response genes several of
them and that if the genes are
co-expressed they often have these
elements in them and our hypothesis is
that we can use those pieces of
information either to edit genes so that
they're better soldiers they're better
respond responders to the resistance
genes or we can breed genome-wide for
more effective defense responses that
are governed by these upstream genes
so yeah I took it out because it would
have taken a long time so with a
chromosome before well you know that's a
if Anna hadn't had to graduate and leave
the lab that would have been the next
steps to she she had a start on cloning
the the target genes there because we've
also got target genes there that we're
interested in and the other thing was to
screen for Magna for thee so I've just
come back from China on Saturday and
I've arranged with some folks there I'm
going to send it to them and have them
screen because we did we don't have the
expertise for Magna forthey in the lab
anymore and rhizoctonia I'm really
interested because we don't have single
gene your assistance for rhizoctonia I'm
really interested in weather because it
might know it could be one of the as I
mentioned it could be that we we've
created a new gene through recombination
that's one possibility or that we've
uncovered resistances that didn't show
up in the parents because we've got them
in two new parent backgrounds there
there may be you know you know QTL so
they can stretch across a half an arm of
the chromosomes through the old mapping
so they're very likely are regions that
were identified for blast this was novel
for a rising in a race ago there were
not there's nothing in that region there
some single genes on chromosome four but
not underneath that qtls so it's it is
novel in that region and it most of the
resistances to that most single gene
resistances to bacterial blight are not
in BL are ours they're not the
traditional to blast they're a lot of
NBL are ours
that region does have NBL R's in it so
it's possible yeah but you just don't
know one of the things that we will also
do if if I survived long enough to do it
will be to sequence those regions to see
and compare them across the different
lines to see how they what they actually
have changed but the the snip profiles
clearly show that they're unique yeah
yeah Andy I knew you have to it can be a
little challenging but I'm wondering
what the genetic resources are for the
parents you have available and how large
structural variation at this region
could impact your mapping locus because
you end up mapping back tomorrow and I
are 64 yeah we have the snip genotypes
for the parents as well but that you
know that's that's crude we know we can
predict which parent for example some of
those QTL we can predict which parent
they came from it's not trivial when you
have 8 parents to do that but we can and
we up but we can predict because of the
if I can just quickly back up to this if
you go to honest paper the full version
of this is in there and you can we can
predict based on the haplotype LeTip ik
block which parent they came from what
that region came from it doesn't mean
it's identical to that parent because it
could have collected some some small
recombination that we don't measure with
my map but we know by the on the block
approximately which region is is
contributing from which parent does that
answer your question
if you look at honest paper and in the I
think it's in the Supplemental
information that's made
much more clear thank you wonderful this
has been a production of Cornell
University on the web at Cornell edu